[Music]
shane is in chicago
hi shane welcome to the show hey thank
you very much
sure what's up so
i as i grew up younger i never wanted to
spend any money
um i'm 27 years old right now and that's
for some reason i was just ingrained in
my brain if i didn't have the money i
couldn't spend it
so like i said i'm 27 uh big three
i have 23 000 in ira
35 grand and a 401k 15 grand another
managed fund
and 103 grand just in the bank
cool so um
i just rent uh no kids not married
and i'm wondering if i can buy a 35 000
uh honda and i've been researching for
the past about
two years because i'm
um i'm kind of researching is one month
two years is lusting
yeah well i can't spend the money you
know
i how much do you make a year
a hundred okay all right chris
you got a hundred and three thousand
dollars in the bank it makes 100 a year
and you make 100 a year shane
um you can go get this car
okay what's standing in the way i'm
um just not i just don't wanna let go of
the money
okay so you're talking about a user or a
new one use it like
uh it's a new one but it's it's i don't
know if you're familiar it's a type r
so they hold they hold their value
pretty well no they don't
like you nothing holds its value with
wheels and motors
they all go down yeah they all go down
years from now 10 years from now it's a
cute little old car
um yeah yeah so uh
you i mean it's a rare car it's a hard
car to find
i bet used or new for that matter um
i i really would buy a one-year-old one
unless you're a millionaire
okay yeah yeah i could buy one used too
for sure yeah if you could buy one with
10 or 12 000 miles on it some guy bought
it and then his wife said he can't have
it anymore or something
and so he puts it up for adoption uh
like a puppy yeah the last thing i want
to say is
yeah i don't want to be because i'm
setting myself so up to save so much i
don't want to be
50 years old and look back and be like
you know what i should have had a little
bit of fun
exactly and bought that car so that's
what i don't want to regret you're very
wise
we teach people to teach their children
and themselves to always and chris and
i've met with athletes making
10 20 million dollars a year and we tell
them the same thing there's three things
you can do with money and you should
always do these three things you should
spend it
and enjoy it in other words you should
be outrageously generous
and you should save in investing and we
try to get folks to do that and
sometimes we meet people who all they
know how to do spend it
sometimes we people only know how to do
give it away and sometimes we meet
people all they know how to do is save
it like you
uh and it's good to learn the other two
skills the generosity skill
and the uh because it makes your life
well-rounded
and a good let me tell you how to do
this uh with
uh wisdom and chris what we do is we
teach that you can talk about this we
talk about the
the ratios when we're dealing with these
athletes that's right and so looking at
this
what i would tell you is in the ratios
the pie graph approach
dave's right the give to save the spin
are absolutely imperative
and you've got to give yourself i can
hear the locked up in your voice
about the thought of spending some money
and you've got to give yourself
permission to be able to enjoy it
so it'll give you the joy of being able
to give it as well
and so right now you got your fists just
so tight i want you to breathe you're
doing well for yourself
put a percentage of your income
on giving a percentage on investing and
a percentage on spending
it doesn't matter if it's two percent
make yourself do
something in all categories okay
yeah okay and then that'll keep you from
having that 55 year old i never live my
life regret
right yeah yeah i'm ready i'm ready to
finally enjoy some of my money versus
all the hard work and
budgeting i've been doing so i think
what's a one-year-old version of that
car called
um a new one right now is the it was 35
what's a one-year-old one cost
uh yeah they're on the market for 32 to
35.
okay all right all right so they're not
taking a big hit the first year then
okay cool how many years they've been
making that car
um they started in 2017. okay so i've
been looking at
2017 but again they're around 32 grand
yeah so i can't find
anything less than that yeah they got
they got great lines
i mean they're just beautiful yeah hunt
that 2017 down chain and get it
well are they 18 or the 19. but yeah i
wouldn't buy brand new
we don't recommend that until you're a
millionaire uh but
you know you're in a position to spend
that kind of money on a car because it's
less than half your annual income you
can pay
cash and i don't think there's any fear
that you're somehow going to go
down a rabbit hole of spending no